I think some nice guys know that someone
who can be absolutely you said you said
the onus isn't on it's not I don't think
the owners of um guys who don't have
confidence to speak to women's on women
that is your personality trait and
that's got nothing to do with me you
don't think I think it can be because I
think this comes so I think these
conversation is that we tend to
generalize a lot and I get it because I
guess that's what is in your in your
view so it's easy to generalize but I
think there are nice guys who because
reading truly it's not like this there's
a lot of nice guys that are single yeah
they're getting girls yeah and some of
them yeah so I think it's just I think
it's easy for us to obviously say that
you know we can talk about certain type
of girls and blah blah because that's
really what's in our view but I don't
believe if I meet a guy who's shy and
whatever I don't believe that women have
women I think he's he's um personality
anyway he's an introvert or he's shy
anyway and maybe that is heightened when
you meet other women and you can't
doesn't have the confidence but I don't
think that Oneness is on women in making
him shy
it's not the onuses on women it's like
we're responsible for the men that we
pick yeah yeah I agree with that part
but she was saying how um she thinks
that guys are like the shy guys they
don't have the Communist approachment
because
partially but it's partially our fault
because feminism had this whole me too
move here yeah so and so like we're
complaining like they're shy because
they don't know if they're going to be
me too if they approach the wrong girl
no no seriously there's
there is a YouTuber that just came out
where he he approached a girl in public
and she literally called the the Park
police on him and this was in 2022. yeah
but there was guys that was shy before
the meeting was started
how old are you I'm 27. like so me too
was what five seven years ago yeah how
long were you really in the dating game
yeah that's the thing because I've got
another life experience okay actually
I'm gonna ask Auntie dude Auntie do you
feel like men approach women more or
less now in the approach women less now
because women look more Fierce they were
more war paint
and because the men are scared
because nowadays it takes a couple of
rare things to happen for all men to be
labeled so now you don't even know
whether to approach a woman or not
because you don't know whether she's
going to say that you're harassing her
leave her alone and sometimes you might
hear this one a woman might just a man
might just want to say excuse me love do
you know that no
take your watch a girl drops something
and I've gone to give it back and she
gave me some dirty look I was like so I
took it I snapped it was Oyster card I
snapped and went and went my way yeah
okay and that's that's why a lot of men
just don't approach women like your
personality trait you can be quite shy
and introvert me personally I'm very
very shy but when you are in a situation
where you feel comfortable you can come
out of your shell and with some guys you
know with some girls they can come out
their shell whereas other women have
made them feel no you stay shy because
women
I don't think that I think guys will
approach you if they feel good about
themselves so if they feel like they're
you know put pushing gym or whatever
that to build their own self-confidence
I I know you guys that feel good about
themselves like they're like yeah I'm
good looking I go to the gym you know
I'm a nice person and he won't approach
a girl but he'll look at a girl and be
like no I won't approach her because we
we like or that girl looks so good and
no no no no no
this is the death of femininity I think
a lot more women are masculine because
back in the day women would signal and
even when we had kit on the other day he
he educates women yeah he educates women
how to signal to allow a man to to feel
comfortable enough to get um to approach
again
maybe the problem is men aren't actually
looking for women's signal before
they're approaching so when a girl is
now calling Paw Patrol is because she's
not signaled to you she's not showed you
she's any interest in you don't know
what her relationship status is and
maybe wait for the cues for a woman
to say this I think women embody
masculinity more now no no but look at
this checklist go on I don't know if
anyone else uses tfl regularly maybe I'm
poor but you know go on the tube you see
the advert I I'm staring harassment yeah
so it puts men on edge yeah
you don't want to approach a girlfriend
no but if we flip it to like countries
where there isn't that a lot of men take
advantage so it's not it these aren't
put in there for women dude the majority
of men are the majority of men the men
you're describing sorry uh the majority
of men Dominion describing so the men
you're saying that take advantage is
that the country like where this isn't
the social norms where you have to but
is that the majority of men
sorry is that do you so the majority
yeah gone do you think the majority of
men are doing that in those countries in
those countries what going up to women
unsolicited yeah 100
and they're grabbing girls the majority
the majority of men in those countries
are grabbing girls 100 so the majority
of men in those countries are committing
assault yes that's your view on man no
no that's not my view on men that's
cultural differences in my country even
where women's rights are not like well
I'm not I'm not here saying women are
equal to them I'm saying but if a woman
doesn't want to be touched don't touch
her that's even a religious side if you
don't touch it I'm with you yeah so in
them countries where what countries like
even parts of Asia Africa can you name
them
I've had men approach me millions and
I've said no no no approaching
you said you said wait wait you said you
said grabbed they were they were okay
even in Dubai they grabbed one of my
friends I've been to Dubai I was fine I
had no issues yeah exactly what I'm
saying again
and I went with my family family sorry
yeah
but also and again maybe this is where
the cultural differences are when it
comes to even like me traveling as an
Asian woman they don't see me as my
British passport they see me as an Asian
woman if I go to Dubai they see me as a
Bangladeshi woman and they will take
advantage of that thinking I'm a
Bangladeshi woman it's just interesting
um because I know a couple people from
those countries and they don't actually
have the same views as you
grew up in the like like um you said
well I think you said Morocco
I'll say this
the context on in which this happened
you were on holiday right and you're
saying that people grabbed you what was
the context of that group no I'm not
saying that they constantly grabbing
this approach they're trying to talk
yeah but are you but can I say as a
Moroccan were you a tourist were you in
a tourist area were you in the Medina
where they're approaching you to sell
you things what no I was just walking
the beach I was walking the beach even
if it's a touristic area what I'm saying
is some countries like even just say
when I go Bangladesh and I'm not a
tourist yeah and I'm in my own country
clothes everything guys will still feel
like they can they have a right to come
and speak to you all okay okay
yeah yeah I'm not saying it's wrong I'm
saying again look at social cues if like
you said the guys teaching girls what
signaling is if she's not making eye
contact if she's not don't maybe don't
approach her especially and that's how
they make guys
but do you see how this is kind of like
the situation that I was describing
because you're kind of like like me
tooing these guys because they
approached okay can I just say as a
victim who has been sexually abused as a
child it's yeah it is deep it is deep
and I don't want if I don't want you
accessing my personal space don't do it
it's not just me too no I talk to
everyone I'm a very social being Eddie
knows I'm very social you trying to
cross that line no like if I've not
necessarily the guy's fault because if
he I personally myself I've been through
the same thing but I would never be able
to look at a guy and say you know it's
your fault if I'm getting mad that
you're coming up and to talk to me I'm
not saying I get mad he doesn't he
doesn't know what's happened to you so
he shouldn't be able to feel like too
shy to still come true I will never call
a man or call police on a man trying to
say hello to me at the park I will smile
and I'll go on my way if he is now
following me and trying to take
advantage of that situation yes I will
panic and that's again my traumas I'll
Panic if he understands oh she doesn't
want to say hello and he might his
business there's no problem I think
that's what that's what it is but you
said the majority of men are grabbing
girls
and that's and that's where like I have
an issue with that because I don't think
you're correct I know people from those
countries and they would not say the
same thing so it's interesting to me
that's your view because it to me that's
like that's like your view on men
I'm not saying that it doesn't happen
I'm not saying it doesn't happen we're
saying it's not the majority okay it
happens it happens
and it might be my figure it might be my
and that's why again I don't like to
when I go especially abroad I don't wear
clothes that will insinuate my figure as
much or my skin because I like to
protect myself yeah it might be that
they find me attractive and they want to
maybe every girl doesn't experience that
but every time I go out I do get
approached or I do get spoken to and I
have to now I smile it's not like I'm
calling police but I'll be like no sorry
I'm not interested or okay yeah no you
know I'm not single and I get I guess
every girl says that to you guys I'm not
single then they'll be like oh what so
yeah you can't have a side boyfriend
yeah
I don't but I don't think like if a
guy's persistent like I'm not I don't
think that's that bad like no one's
saying it's bad it's like I don't think
I don't think he should grab you I think
that's like okay don't don't but like
you're telling me you you went to this
country and every single guy you saw are
like let's say so the majority so it's a
six out of ten guys you saw grabbed you
no not grab they will approach me okay
but approaching is an assault no it's
not that it's an assault but it could
lead hold up if I keep smiling and
entertaining it and not saying putting
my boundary on he might think oh she's
interested and it's very hard for
sometimes I feel like we say yes just
because it's easier like I take guy's
number just because that's not their
fault like to me like if a guy
approaches me again again like it's
annoying but who cares like I I've been
in like I've I went to Martinique I
don't know if you've heard of it yeah
it's nice nice and like guys there
they're like at this beach would like
come up to me and I'm like who cares I'd
be like go away okay but maybe um sorry
babes I think it can be intimidating I
think the way a person can approach you
like I think some people I think it
depends on each Essence like how you are
I guess but I think sometimes the way
even the way a guy will approach you can
make you uncomfortable I'm a confident
person
and I've had guys approach me that's
made me feel intimidated I've given guys
my number just so that this interaction
can end I've had some I went to a party
one time and the guy was like I think it
was a security at the venue and I left
and I didn't realize he was following me
and I'm walking down a dark Road I get
in my car thankfully as soon as I get in
the car I lock the doors I lock the door
he's like he's like oh that trying to
get my attention I was like oh I'm not
interested because this is I feel unsafe
in this situation he stood there he
stood there getting his phone out like
he's talking to me I'm looking at him
like bro and I was annoying because I
was in a tight space I couldn't just
kind of just drive off so I think some
guys it can be like it's just the way
they approach that they don't approach
you in a way that makes you feel
comfortable as many of you know I was
just banned on Tick Tock and we are
demonetized on a daily basis on this
platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible